this video is sponsored by research hub
now I know what you're thinking wouldn't
it be great if someone made a video on
all the longevity research highlights
that came out in 2022
well hello you've come to the right
place
and to help with navigation I have
broken down this video into categories
and the timestamps can be found in the
description box we'll begin with
lifespan regulation studies then discuss
Rejuvenation and regeneration then my
personal favorite cellular lessen
Essence then some technology papers and
then lifestyle and then end with some
aging mechanism papers and as I don't
have the time to fully go through all
the papers here I'll put the links to
the individual videos or you can
continue the discussion over at research
Hub but more on that later so let's go
now is it getting hot in here or is it
just me no not me just this hot paper on
how body temperature not metabolic rates
seems to be modulating lifespan and
rodents the experiments on in this paper
involves placing mice above their Thermo
neutral zone to increase their body
temperature and decrease metabolic rate
they also repeated this but they had a
fan blowing over the mice and this wind
prevented the increase in body
temperature but the metabolic rate still
dropped the animals housed at this
higher temperature without wind lived
shorter than animals housed at 21
degrees
however when the animals exposed to this
higher temperature were exposed to wind
the reduction on lifespan was no longer
present all in all this paper suggested
that body temperature is more important
than metabolic crates for modulating
lifespan in these mice
I think the study has many limitations
but it raises the importance of
temperature and lifespan regulation
moving on this year we also had some
updates from the interventions testing
program I discussed how the program
works in another video but essentially
it's a matter program that tests
different compounds and genetically
diverse mice to see if this extends our
lifespan so the initial focus is on
lifespan not in the health biometrics
anyway most of the current trials are
still underway but a publication came
out further investigating one compound
canoglyphosan which was previously shown
in this intervention setting program and
to extend lifespan male mice
here they further showed that carnegly
phosan significantly diminished the
incidence of lesions representing five
organs in male mice as shown by the
distribution of lesbian scores
strangely though this compound also
increased water intake urination and
bladder size in the memos and just a
quick plug to say that I interviewed
Professor Rich Muller who coordinates
much of the interventions testing
program so you can find more details
there
anyway the compound that has most
consistently performed well in these
interventions testing program studies as
Rich says most famous of these I think
at this point is rapamycin in particular
because rapamycin even when given later
life extends lifespan in the mice
and So speaking of rapamycin a study
came out showing that early life
exposure to rapamycin also increased
lifespan here in mice daily from
postnatal day 4 to 30 in both sexes by
around nine percent
however there was no significant
extension when rapamycin was given from
day 30 to 60. but it's worth mentioning
that the mice treated from day 4 to 30
had a severe reduction in body size to
controls which maybe isn't surprising
given that rapamycin inhibits mtol which
promotes cell growth but importantly the
study implicates that early life
treatments can have long-term
consequences
and the study giving rapamycin to mice
at the early stage of their life
has also been seen in this other
pre-prints from fadim gladyshev's Lab
where they gave the mice rapamycin for
the first 45 days the median lifespan
was extended by 10 and the effects were
greater in male mice and also in a study
they observed the smaller body size
but rapamycin chronically flows down and
body temperature manipulation could be
considered during protective strategies
but another concept we've had much more
understanding on this year are
rejuvenative approaches reversing the
aging process
so one paper that led to a lot of news
articles was this one multi-amic
Rejuvenation of naturally aged tissues
by a single cycle of transient
reprogramming which is a fancy sounding
title so to summarize in this paper they
do partial reprogramming as opposed to
the full reprogramming of differentiated
cells into stem cells pioneered by
shenya yamanaka by ever expressing the
yamanaka factors and so this partial
reprogramming methods that they termed
maturation phase transients free
programming is instead of exposing the
cells to 50 days of yamanaka gene
expression they instead got 13 days and
instead of the cells losing their
identity in full reprogramming and
becoming stem cells
they remain in this case as skin cells
and are partially rejuvenated or
partially reprogrammed and here this was
demonstrated by these partially
rejuvenated cells having increased
collagen production and reducing the
epigenetic age and continuing with the
theme of partial reprogramming I covered
this paper on inferior parcel
reprogramming where they evaluated
longer term partial reprogramming in
normal mice
and by partial reprogramming in this
context it means expressing these
yamanaka reprogramming factors for short
time period with periods when they are
not expressed
so the cell will start to reprogram but
it does not completely refer to a stem
cell and lose its identity as we just
saw in the other paper
and the way they did it here was to use
a genetic construct in the mice
expressing the yamanaka factors which
they could control when it was switched
on with a drug and they switched on the
expression for two days and then the
mice had five days without it and then
they did this iteratively for seven or
ten months
the main changes they observed from the
study was that there was a reduction in
gene expression linked with senescence
and inflammation and my conclusion at
the time was that this paper felt more
like a mechanistic rather than a
functional study and whatever they were
doing to them eyes just seemed to be
well tolerated as there is no lifespan
data presented in this publication
anyway next up is this paper that showed
cellular reprogramming of human cells
using chemicals now another quick plug I
will be doing a journal Club on this
paper on Zoom I believe as part of
research Hub and Fetal
um there should be some more details
hopefully I can show in the description
by the time I finish making this video
but who knows I'll keep you updated
nonetheless but to Briefly summarize
this paper Haley wanted to do the full
reprogramming not the partial
reprogramming and instead of using the
yamanaka factors they use chemicals and
that's what they did they converted
human adult somatic cells into
pluripotent cells very interesting stuff
and I highly recommend you joining in on
this journal club that I'll do next week
all right moving from cellular
reprogramming to tissue regeneration
just last week I spoke about antler
regeneration and reindeer in response to
skin injury the molecular and cellular
response was compared with the back skin
of the Reindeer and the authors
identified some inflammatory signaling
molecules more highly expressed in the
back skin by inhibiting one of these
proteins the csfr1 receptor it enhanced
regeneration and a rodent wound model so
the study highlights the importance of
examining other organisms that possess
regenerative properties and what we can
learn from them and speaking of
regeneration a very cool study came out
showing a wearable bioreactor that
enables multi-drug delivery to
facilitate long-term limb regeneration
here demonstrated in frogs so adult
frogs a bit like us have limited
regenerative capacities and touring this
paper they show limb regrowth and
functional restoration of frogs after
amputation of their hind limb after they
were wearing a wearable bioreactor
and the bioreactor contained a cocktail
of chemicals including 140 PCA bdnf a
neurotrophic factor growth hormone and
retinoic acids I interviewed Michael
Levin about his research on this paper
earlier this year then maybe next year I
will make a more complete regeneration
themed video and so with all this
exciting news in Rejuvenation it's also
worth mentioning that there are now many
biotech companies focusing on
rejuvenative approaches such as those
seen listed in this table here and I
discussed more about it in this previous
video
now being your cellular senescence
YouTuber
of course we needed to mention some of
the senescence papers that came out this
year
so firstly shouting out the summer of
the articles that some of my lab mates
did you were up guys
here are some other highlights I have
the color slab can old blood induce
senescence well it can apparently
according to this paper this suggests
that there are factors in old blood that
can have a systemic deleterious effect
and supports the blood's dilution
neutral blood exchange we learned about
last year from the comboy's which builds
upon the classic heterochronic
parabiasis experiments trying to
understand if there was something
rejuvenative about young Bloods or there
was something deleterious about all
Bloods and it seems like this paper
supports the latter Theory and
unsurprisingly this paper came out from
the Convoy lab along with Judith Campisi
the senescence Queen
the other interesting finding from this
paper was that when the old mice were
treated of cenolytics before blood
exchange it's attenuated the pro-aging
effect and they claim that senescence is
neither simply a response to stress and
damage that's increases of age
interesting ideas we'll have to revisit
it at some points
now I just mentioned cinematics without
explaining what they are and whilst
analytics or drugs started defined as
selectively killing senescent cells
um the drugs that are being tested
currently in different clinical trials
most frequently are the combination of
the Satanism question
now a landmark paper came out showing
that this combination improved the
health and increased median survival of
mice
and some human data suggested that this
combination could alleviate physical
dysfunction in ipf patients anyway
there's paper from this year father
looked at these data sets and found that
by using these analytics it's increased
the levels of this protein called Alpha
clotho
now Alpha clotho is a receptor protein
that is mainly produced by the liver and
regulates phosphate levels in the body
but can also get cleaved and has roles
in endocrine signaling and a long
incomplete story short when
overexpressed in miter Auto increases
lifespan so if cellulitics can increase
Alpha cloth though that may provide some
explanation for the apparent anti-aging
lifespan benefits and then most recently
we've had this publication of a
senescence Atlas I've only had times of
brutally skin read this paper but what
they did was isolate senescent cells
from mice which is no trivial task
um and these mice that had muscle injury
and they did this in both young and old
mice so they were focusing on the
skeletal muscle Niche and for my
superficial summary as I've not fully
read it yet it seems that senescent
cells are blocking regeneration even in
young mice and it might induce harmful
changes and aged muscle frankly I'm a
little confused what to think as
senescence is meant to enhance
regeneration and skin wounds SSL tissue
specific context dependence probably
likely who knows I haven't read the
paper so sorry but I definitely will
read this at some point as I'll probably
need to include it in my thesis foreign
[Music]
cool so now we're going to move over to
some technological advances that could
facilitate future research in the Aging
fields
firstly there was this paper that
expands pun intended upon a technique
called expansion microscopy which
essentially if you're Imaging a sample
instead of zooming in using the
microscope lens human said expand the
sample and due to isotropically
facilitating super resolution imaging
this walk was pioneered by Ed Boyden at
MIT who I actually interviewed the other
month and will hopefully get the
interview out soon but anyway in this
paper they developed an iterative
version of expansion microscopy to
achieve expansion or feeling and could
see amyloids nanoclusters in brain
tissue from a mouse model of Alzheimer's
disease
now this worked because the expansion as
they call it causes molecular decrouding
giving access to antibodies enabling
them to see these periodic clusters in
the amyloid beta plaques while without
this expansion they could only just
detect the large plaque centers and so
the interesting thing is that this new
technology will enable new questions to
be asked about neurodegenerative
diseases but I'm sure it could also be
applied to many other cases
quite different we also have a new
crispr Gene editing tool on the horizon
called paste now I will make a video on
this in a new year so what bus of time
then now to hit that subscribe button
anyway the research is behind Pace we're
trying to fill the cup
but without making gaps
to add large genomic sequences into the
genome
now what I mean by this is that current
Crystal approaches either add smaller
sequences removal change bases and they
depend on DNA damage signaling and
repair processes
whereas paste is here to solve this
problem and as handedly
provided by the authors a one sentence
summary
pace is a new technology combining
crispr mediator genome editing and
site-specific integrases enables
efficient programmable Gene integration
at any targeted genomic Locus without
double strand DNA breaks ligaments of
broad applications and basic science
research cell engineering and gene
therapy so I think it's pretty clear I'm
gonna have to make a video on this at
some point so yes moving on the whole
genome sequence was also finally
sequenced this year now I know what
you're thinking surely we did that back
in 2001 with the Human Genome Project
well
I mean I was far I don't really remember
but for my research we did a decent
amount but we left the really
challenging bits like the bits agrees
that you can't quite remove when you're
washing it up until now we now have the
full sequence
and so that gives rise to potentially
some more genome comparison studies
we'll see we'll see what happens with
this data who knows because um genetics
is important but then service lifestyle
and this year I also highlighted a few
studies in this category
firstly I made a video that investigated
when during the day is the best time to
eat I looked in particular at these two
studies late ISO caloric eating
increases hunger decreases energy
expenditure and modifies metabolic
pathways in adults with overweights and
obesity and timing of daily calorie
loading affects appetites and hunger
responses without changes in energy
metabolism in healthy subjects with
obesity
and these studies suggested benefits for
eating Olio but as I mentioned in the
video at the time being small scale
studies for short time periods with
confounding factors
it's hard to conclude much but I would
like to see some more studies looking at
the intersection of diets food timing
and circadian rhythms
and alternatively to when we eat there's
also how much and this year we had some
more information from the color retrial
a comprehensive assessment of long-term
effects of reducing intake of energy so
calorie restriction and in the study
they looked at how calorie restriction
impacted the immune system of
participants compared with controls two
years of an on average 14 calorie
restriction
it significantly increased the thymic
mass and volume and showed indicators
that they were still producing T cells
this suggested that the effects of
calorie restriction are protective
now if you've made it this far through
the video you may need a brain boost
ing to say
which brings us to the study that
investigated how selenium a chemical
element that is essential for our bodies
mediates exercise induced adult
neurogenesis
selenium can get incorporated into
so-called cellino proteins and this
study suggests that release of
selenoprotein p is important for
neurogenesis enhancing effects of
exercise
part of the effect of neurogenesis and
mice could be restored through just
selenium supplementation
so that brings us to papers I've grouped
into as aging related and speaking of
Aging I'll be any closer to a definition
let's start with this paper which I
think will become a landmark paper
somatic mutation rate scales with
lifespan here they used fancy DNA
sequencing techniques to examine
mutations from different organisms at
different ages and to calculate a
mutation rates which they could then
compare across species and found that
there was a correlation between the
maximum lifespan of the organism and the
mutation rate
they did this by looking at intestinal
tissue but this is nonetheless
interesting for a number of reasons
which I explained in this full video but
it suggests that improving DNA repair
could be one way to counteract aging
and conveniently DNA repair is what we
will talk about next with this paper
where our human centenarian variant of
so two and six what identified that
enhances genome stability now it was
actually last year I did a deep dive
video into twin six and I highlighted
how there was the correlation here
between lifespan and Saturn 6 activity
isosce2 and 6 is an enzyme found in the
nucleus of a cell where the DNA is with
two known catalytic activities one of
the diacetalase where it removes acetyl
groups and one of the ribosylase where
it adds ADP ribose which is just NAD
without nicotinamides anyway the
centenarian variants possessed increased
robotics activity and decreased the
acetylase activity so finding molecules
that can activate citizen sex but
specifically the ribosylation aspect is
no doubt of Interest
and speaking of the nucleus just last
week this paper came out on how nuclear
phagey delays aging what is nucleophagy
a good question it is the selective
breakdown of nuclear components so a
selective type of autophagy my brief
summary here is that nucleophagy
is important for instructing the
nucleola size which has been previously
linked to longevity
a topic I may dig into next year
and to end let's end with the end of DNA
telomers telomeres are protective
repetitive elements at the ends of DNA
every time a cell divides the telomere
shorten once they get too short a cell
can enter replicative senescence even
cells that Express the enzyme telomerase
that extends the telomeres such as T
cells can't prevents in essence during
proliferative expansion of T cells this
paper showed that antigen presenting
cells provides telomeric repeats two t
cells rescuing the T cells from senatins
and promoting long-term immunological
memory so some altruistic cell cell
communication
and speaking of altruistic communication
come and join me over at research Hub
also the sponsor for this video research
Hub is a platform where researchers can
upload articles summarize and discuss
the findings in reward for a research
coin the overall aim is to accelerate
the pace of scientific research and to
make it more accessible I've already
been using the site for over a year now
and have uploaded the papers relevant to
this video so you find the link to
research Hub in the description so with
that happy New Year let me know what
papers I've missed probably quite a few
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening